però tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video finalmente maledizione oggi
è uscito cioè io sto registrando oggi
che è uscito cyberpunk 2077 gioco
rimandato 62 volte prima di cominciare
però ragazzi sono qui per annunciarvi
che mamma nvidia mi ha inviato questa
per l'età geforce rtx 3080 che è molto
più grande come numero di 2077 tutto ciò
in occasione appunto velocità di cyber
punk per poterlo sfruttare al meglio
questa fantastica bomba andrà montata
all'interno del mio computer
tra poco tratto io farò il nuovo setup
settimana prossima lo vedrete avrà
all'interno questa qua ma per adesso
montiamo la sul mio e voliamo con
cyberpunk amici della compagnia
dell'anello o aver avviato cyberpunk e
già tenta di hacker armi con guarda
sigla viso di sicurezza windows
innanzitutto vediamo la grafica
raytracing a tutto alto ma chi se ne
frega tutto alto tutto ho messo a ultrà
ma il ragazzo io sono più server fa
anche 2077 siamo arrivati a dire che sta
potuta frase finalmente let's go e fammi
vedere come si sveglia sotto gioco
maledetto dai e gustare mtx di 12.000
allora ei giomba che senso non
acconsento niente fammi giocare
possiamo scegliere tra nomade vita di
strada e corporativo io sapevo già di
questa scelta iniziale ovviamente la
cavolate varie recensioni cose vado sul
corporativo selezionate l'operazione adv
tal vai a via il personaggio principale
travolta il soul penso aspetto può
influenzare il comportamento gli altri
personaggi
allora premessa totale io conosco la
meravigliosa doppiatrice dvb come cazzo
si dice che si chiama martina pelli che
era meravigliosa poi c'è anche di anna
baker ed è anche la voce di zelda la
voce videoludica per eccellenza martina
felli che ha doppiato il protagonista
femminile di sai baba che non potremo
non scegliere tutti quanti di
protagonista femminile che ha la sua
voce sentite qua io sono di musica per
le mie orecchie quando grande vocali e
sempre un'emozione colore
occhio va peggio un lounge bar ragazzi
challenge mode negli occhi
no ragazze niab dove non ho parole gli
occhi a cuoricino gli occhi di sauron
basta ho trovato a tipo ingross ma dai
ma si vedono le tette proprio fichissimo
mio gioco preferito capezzoli stato si
vede quindi posso fare quello che voglio
dovete solo giampiero è goditela
giardino questo è un prode lavorare con
the broom ragazzi martina la voce di b
mi ha risposto adesso perché le ho detto
che avrei registrato cyberpunk rimandato
vocale adesso vediamo
sono 20 ma anche esplorare in ai siti
con messali jane martin meravigliosa e
con questo ragazzi è che possiamo
cominciare una vera partita come si deve
al cyberpunk nel modo migliore poi farò
anche il video con lei come ho fatto con
jean per spider man e fare un video con
martina per per cyberpunk e del tutto
giochero con lei
ecco dico a martina la cosa è dipendente
e ne cisse perfetto siamo partiti
benissimo
va bene ce ne andiamo in malesia allora
ragazzi siamo oltre che ci siamo io
staranno in giro a caso si aprì bloccato
ma tron quanto credo sia un mondo enorme
ciao
devo andare da una parte che non so
neanche dove quindi non mi rompete le
scatole scusate se vi arrivò subito
arrivo sistemare questa eccoci prima
sedia e tipo i meeting che facciamo su
zoom però un po più cazzuto ragazzi
scusate vi semi interrompo ma sta roba è
associare il senso io non ho capi non i
non ho ben capito se effettivamente poi
il mondo sarà completamente percorribile
quindi io posso andare esattamente in
ogni posto che state vedendo io sto
ancora aspettando in una maniera
incredibile
l'apparizione di keanu reeves da un
momento all'altro che ma comunque a
prescindere lui mi sembra un figo
se devo essere sincero mettiamoci al
lavoro è il momento dell'azione ragazzi
vediamo se riusciamo a spaccare abbiamo
fatto un salto temporale di un attimo e
che se non c'eravamo più per la riassumo
praticamente mi hanno rubato tutto
quello che avevo ed adesso io all'inizio
con
una nuova vita con questo ragazzone sono
già passati sei mesi dal filmato
iniziale dottor dove gli ammazzo ti
ammazzo ti ammazzo accovacciandosi
questo non è accovacciato si è la talea
ci viene scarico al momento
ma di qualcosa
poi non sono uno che ammazza le persone
qualche bravo che sono un alimento nei
primi frigoriferi a posto raga domanda
ma è proprio necessario tenere la musica
a palla nel 2077 possiamo anche
toglierla non è necessario tener la re
non è morto non è morto non muore amico
spara togliti che ci sta uno li di
bianco togliti madonna e casinò aica
porco del demonio io sto ancora posto di
vita ragazzo rimasto in tre il pieno di
gente
no ragazzi colpiti è veramente dire
quanta cassidy non bacio beh comunque
c'è anche da dire che ho selezionato la
difficoltà difficile c'è anche quello da
dire
quindi non è proprio semplice come puoi
metterla radio mentre sfoglia la gente
di attente a ma posso fare il giro al
contrario fighissimo
perfetto manca 1
madonna grossissimo provate da mina ma
non sto facendo tutto io
minchia due ore
grazie a questo affare mi servirà credo
ho visto quanto faceva schifo l'altra
arma comunque ragazzi in questa cosa qua
l'avevo già vista a los angeles quando
ero andato a vedere cyberpunk sono morti
l'obiettivo è giampiero non solo
preparare censura sta roba
per scoprirlo ragazzi io mi devo mettere
a guardare in alto per cercare di
censurare il più possibile i seni eccoci
seguire una sega che qua c'è un attiva
in mano aiuto per favore lasciate fa
niente di traumatico da regalo ragazzi
fa come barella a questa la barella
cinque passi indietro adesso
e la madonna ma la gente è tutto a posto
e non guardiamo noi guardiamo fratello
pensa che censurare il suo video per
giampiero deve essere un punto nel q1
stimolanti ma porca [ __ ] spiega almo
maghi le bottiglie ho fatto questa gente
di parma si sono gloria
vabbè tutto a posto e ragga tranquilli
ma avresti dovuto ascoltarti
ma non rompere le palle break sono a
casa mia ho una casa un po delle palle
visto che c'è anche un cestino che va a
fuoco però questo è normale insomma tipo
imposti di merda tutto a posto ragazze
viola avanti dell'ascensore voler ero lì
con la madonna nicola ma come sei messo
bene nicola nico la bellissima
voglio una lattina di cola per favore
per favore voglio della nicole allora
questa è la città poi uscire fare quello
che cacchio voi non adesso perché siamo
all'inizio travagliata rigido e farmi
cazzi miei salve ragazzi tutto ok a
posto è non pensavo potessi far del male
a gente a caso e questa cosa non volevo
non volevo ma succede adesso
scherzavo via via via via via via via
via tra scherzando scherzando che se la
cava dei casi e casi casa che di chi mi
ha portato a porte chiuse la porta
aperta po troppo troppo tanta troppa
portato a quota proferiva portali la
bastata la tratta niente facili non è
successo niente né a dormire a dormire è
na na na na dormire e dormire e dormire
qua ci sono armi sul muro dormire dove
si dorme in questo posto di match siamo
raga sono mai siti sono nei siti anche
se giorno quindi giorno city l'attività
scanna siete già chi frega un cazzo ti
sei vado via voglio andare a fare un
giro fammi fare un giro ho finalmente
ciao amici possono rubare la macchina
prendi il controllo della macchina forte
sega ciao
dovevo fare questa cosa
brooklyn paris st raga il momento da
quando la patente guardate 2 guido tutto
a posto raga come se niente fosse
infatti no vabbè ma questo è il gioco
che mi piace per il culo e non so stato
io comunque stiamo a nexity finalmente è
il momento di andare in giro a capire un
attimo poi zona questa città splendida
let's go bike boys ricordate i ragazzi
sempre guardare avanti modo guidate che
sarà poi perfino citando
fiat 500 che sta nel 2077 tra l'altro di
un po un problema porto ingegneria rosa
cano come stiamo andando in realtà non
so neanche come la mappa qua eccoci la
madonna tra l'altro la casta macchina
cia dei pannelli solari sul tettuccio
cioè si alimenta la canzone north side
che lo sta andando la gestione della
gente e un'attenzione apertura vicini
funziona così creato da poliziana la
polizia sia poliziotti o celati pentiva
per miracolo e ci si arrivato tutto una
granata regalo investo c'è un trono si è
fatto rubare una macchina del tempo
questa vediamo se riesco rubarla questa
cosa c'entra che tipici ma questo cosa
vuol dire ma cosa vuol dire ho rubato la
ma non c'e questo paesino buona macchina
e lui ho dei figli
questa ragazzi questa è una vera
macchina non quale prima comunque
ragazzi allora impressioni a caldo
adesso lui lascio le moto prima medie
imprese nel caso prendiamo la moto
aspetta un attimo prima busta re di vita
dei viola moto appena modo di vedere
come va
ci sono arresto è bello
stavo dicendo allora ragazzi vi dove le
impressioni a caldo dio benedetto
scusate scusate scusate non voler
guidare le impressioni a caldo ragazzi
allora molto bello perché va bene questo
indiscutibile fatto del gioco sia
spettacolare ti dico però la verità ma
magari perché siamo all'inizio mi sembra
un po c'è rispetto all'aspettativa che
mi ero creato io
su cyberpunk è un po meno ma perché io
mi hanno creato cioè io non ho mai visto
nella mia vita un gioco così poi fatto
come cyberpunk e prima dello sci bravo
che in italia la strada zia complimento
non avevo mai visto un gioco così tanto
pompato a livello di pubblicità a robben
e quindi mi ero fatto un'aspettativa
stellare è questo che mi frega perché
quando tutti i file aspettativa stellare
poi il gioco deve essere c'è io
veramente non ho mai visto un gioco così
compatto come sai per far carico di
comicità
io facevo un'aspettativa finale bene
spero che visto che oggi i ragazzi vi
sia piaciuto questo la cyber punk 2077
con la nuova scheda scheda grafica che
vedo che lo pompa a manetta questa una
grafica massimizzata totale ringrazio si
p project red anche per non solo per la
chiave di sai per quanto ma anche per lo
zaino di cyber punk e man mano mandato
bellissimo e niente spero che vede vi
sia piaciuto come società che ha seguito
bisogno assoluto è un bel mi piace
fatemi sapere se volete altri video su
cyberpunk e ringrazio anche martina che
mi ha reso tutto questo mi ha allietato
questa giocata con la sua splendida voce
vedrete il prossimo video di cyber punk
e probabilmente con lei e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video e
ragazzi
[Musica]